welcome back to the big saturday show it
looks like it's an end of an era the
goat
may be gone
there are reports that tom brady is
retiring
but brady's agent an espn reporter told
an espn reporter i understand the
advanced speculation about tom's future
without getting into the accuracy or
inaccuracy of what's being reported tom
will be the only person to express his
plans with complete accuracy he knows
the reality of the football business and
planning in a planning calendar as well
as anybody so that should be soon
a few months ago earlier in the season
the buccaneers quarterback had this to
say
i think my
wife has
you know held down the house for a long
time now and i think there's things that
she wants to accomplish um you know
she's
hasn't worked as much in the last 10 12
years just raising our family and kind
of committing to being a lot in a life
in boston and then moving to florida but
it's here you know it's a very difficult
issue to reconcile without just saying
hey it's time to retire um
and i think there's you know we're
coming to the end here too so i don't
want to miss any of the kids stuff
charlie obviously i'm i'm having a very
difficult time with this uh you know as
a as a kid who was a lifelong patriot
fan and our biggest claim to flame was
being mollywop by the chicago bears
where they even got a music video at our
expense
uh you know tom brady changed the
culture he we went from the team
everybody wants to play the team nobody
wants to play so you know uh this is
this is tough for me charlie
what does this mean to you tom brady
obviously you can tell i'm emotional
wreck but i would imagine you would be
tough this is tough on you as well
uh actually it's not it's probably not
as tough on me as it is thank you
charlie if we could just go to carling
right now
but
but but that said i gotta say i don't
even like football and i especially
don't like the nfl this is blasphemy i'm
sorry let me cut his feet down but hold
on hold on but tuning in
every week to tom brady has become
something over the last couple of years
i mean i can't stop the guy's almost as
old as somebody all right all right
every week and and and the idea that
what last week it was three minutes to
go with two touchdowns it's amazing i
know all this two touchdowns down and
sure enough tom brady winds up tying the
game it is absolutely amazing and
obviously we don't know what he's going
to do but what i really love about this
whatever he decides to do it's going to
be whatever his wife tells him to do and
i just love it that you can be the
greatest of all time and you still have
to do whatever your wife tells you to do
that's right
okay charlie i'm kind of on the fence
i'm not sure if that was positive
negative but i'm too emotional right now
[Laughter]
carly you know besides you know tom
brady's accomplishments besides touching
all of our hearts and minds uh i've i've
heard that he's been uh referred to as a
saint maybe you could just share one of
your favorite tom brady moments
well i've been listening to tom brady
propaganda ever since i met my husband
he's a huge uh michigan fan so i mean
tom brady is like all that is
uh in our household and i like tom brady
too
and i think the most impressive thing
about him is his work ethic i watched
the um tom vs time documentary on it was
a facebook docu-series on him that aired
a few years ago he'd already been in the
nfl for like 20 years at the time and he
was still trying to perfect his throwing
motion just practice you know after
practice during the off season he would
watch hours and hours of um game footage
and he even said that you know sometimes
he loses track of time like six hours in
he's still watching game footage and
also the way he um takes care of his
body is insane with the diet he doesn't
eat he doesn't eat any of the things
that bring life joy
dairy coffee sugar gluten alcohol he
doesn't eat nightshade vegetables
tomatoes potatoes mushrooms so hopefully
if he does retire
um he's a great dad he could spend some
time with his kids maybe they can have a
pizza party eat all the naughty things
that he normally doesn't eat when he's
playing
you know this is it's just getting worse
because you're so right i mean he made
avocado toast the thing without the
toast
emily if i could just share with you uh
how much i i love uh
saint brady uh just you know like say a
few things like i'd like to count the
ways 1 1 000.
1 000. tyrus 3 1 000. no need to keep
crying breaking news guys a reporter
caught up with brady's dad who
apparently has called all of this an
unsubstantiated rumor it seems to me
like an episode of lost where everyone
was like wait you know there was the the
gray rock that was placed differently on
the shelf because first of all part of
it came out of brady saying on a podcast
that he was quote satisfied with his
career everyone said this is a guy who's
never satisfied to carly's point and
then we know that giselle might be sort
of the yoko ono right we know that she's
enlisted friends to help him
to help convince him to retire she's
spoken openly that she doesn't quite
like seeing him get thrown around on the
field um and note as well i think this
is an important statistic he still has
almost 25 million dollars left on his
contract that's probably a drop in the
bucket for how much the two of them make
combined but it might enable him to have
some type of uh incentive to keep
emma thank you so much i feel so much
better i was just playing i wasn't
really crying i knew he wasn't going to
retire i knew it was all it was all fake
news hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else